CANUCKS IN ABBOTSFORD AND THIS
IS HIS SECOND NATIONAL HOCKEY
THE ROAD JUST A GAME OVER .500
AND THEY WOULD LIKE TO TURN THAT
HE BLUES GET IT
OUTSIDE OF THE
CREASE AND INTERCEPTING.
>> John S.: STOPPING SIX OF
GOT IN FRONT OF IT. AND H H
AND WRISTER STOPPED BY
SSON UNIT
STAYING OUT FOR THE OFFENSIVE
ZONE FACE-OFF AND THAT PASS FOR
HUGHES, OUT OF HIS LOST HIS
STICK.
>> John S.: ANDEP.
THAT PUCK, CENTRED, PRESSURE
FROM THE BLUES, PARAYKO KEEPI SD
HERE NOW IT IS DiPIETRO YOU SAI,
KEEPING I
>> John G.: SCANDELLA, A BROKEN
STICK.
>> John S.: THIS NOW TO
PEARSON, UP TO HUGHES WITH 30 P.
PENALTIES ARE OVER AND THE BLUES
NOW BACK TO FULL STRENGT CROSS-.
>> John G.: AND ALL
A
>> Announcer: BE A PLAYER.
BET ON HOCKEY LIKE NEVER BEFORE
CHECK IN THE CORNER AND
>> John G.: AND YOU SAID THAT
THAT WAS IN OVERTIM THE
NHL, JUST OVER 29% BUT THE
PO FAULK, THAT WAS AT 18:33
THERE, IN FRONT.
AND WHAT A NICE PASS. 30 SECONDK
WITH. THE POWER PLAY.
>> John G.: OH, BOY, NOT A LOT E
PANTHERS HAVE BEEN DOING
OFFENSIVELY AGAINLK NOW BACK TOU
WHO IS
TARASENKO.AND YOU CAN SEE THAT ,
AN ASSIST FOR FAULK AND
AND TUCKER POOLMAN NOW, OVER TO
JUSTIN BAILEY, MIS STEAL, PEARSN
IN FRONT AND BOESER MISSING THA.
THIS 4:20NOW
LAMMIKKO,
AN ICING CALL WITH THE